lassen Sie uns noch einmal kurz ernst werden
wenn es Bumm macht und Menschen aufeinander
schießen dann ist es entweder Hauptschule
oder Krieg und damit sind wir bei einer
Besonderheit unserer Zeit der Krieg ist zurück
die Zustimmung zum tornadoeinsatz in Syrien hat
unseren Bundestag nur eine Woche Beratungszeit
und genau ein müdes Arsch Runzeln gekostet ist
natürlich auch einer sagen wir mal deutsche
Tradition also vor ungefähr 70 Jahren da hat
noch jeder Deutsche im Kreuzworträtsel bei
Pauschalreise mit 14 Buchstaben instinktiv
einmarschieren geschrieben aber ich sag
mal heute darf man doch mal fragen was
wir aus unseren Fehlern lernen über 10
Jahre Bundeswehreinsatz in Afghanistan
haben dem Land nicht wirklich zu einer viel
besseren Bewertung bei Tripadvisor verholfen
vielleicht könnte man zur Abwechslung wenigstens
mal irgendwo einmarschieren wo wir auch eine
kleine Chance haben zu gewinnen auf Borkum oder
so keine Ahnung ne dann natürlich der brutale
Kontrast zwischen Anspruch und Wirklichkeit also
zwischen Weltherrschaft und Schrott Bundeswehr
Mann spricht ja schon von Uschis Restaurant
Rampe es gibt Kampfhubschrauber die werden
nur noch von Tesafilm und von der lines Haarspray
zusammengehalten seit Jahrzehnten lassen Sie sich
von der Rüstungsindustrie über den Tisch ziehen
und verbrennen Milliarden an Steuer Kohle z.B
auch für das inzwischen legendäre G36 das
ungefähr so schießt wie ein Mädchen wird
also nicht gut ja mit dem Teil
triffst du wohl nur sehr dicke Taliban
die mitdenken und so freundlich sind sich gar
nicht zu bewegen auch ist wohl vorgekommen
dass eine Waffe im dauerbrauch also schnell Feuer
geschossen wurde bei SWAT teams und die ist ganz
einfach geschmolzen na bitte das G36 schmilzt
in der Hand und nicht im Mund ja man zielt auf
den linken Taliban und der rechte fällt um das
nennt sich asymmetrische Kriegsführung sehr modern
das wären aber so Baustellen um die
man sich mal kümmern könnte bevor
man deutsche Soldaten jetzt auch noch
nach Syrien oder Mali schickt und was
macht Ursula von der Leyen die
kreißsa-legende aus Burgdorf ja
sie gibt Pressekonferenzen zum Thema
Kita-Plätze und WLAN-Anschlüsse für
Kasernen um unmissverständlich klar zu
machen die Bundeswehr ist im Prinzip
ganz normale Firma gut außer das wütende
Kunden gelegentlich auf einen schießen aber
das Erleben Service Mitarbeiter
der Telekom ja auch natürlich
und zwar zu Recht von alleine von der Leyen
sagt ernsthaft ich will die besten jedes
Jahrgangs für die Bundeswehr die besten und
man denkt wir reden aber schon noch von den
Typen die früher jeden Freitag die Regionalbahn
Folge kurz haben oder Uschi wenn du den helfen
willst dann rüste sie gefälligst anständig aus
immer mehr Auslandseinsätze gut und schön aber
wie kommt man dahin ganz einfach du hast einen
Auslandseinsatz und weiß nicht wie du hinkommen
sollst weil Uschis Trans alle Maschinen mal
wieder im Arsch sind dann hör auf zu heulen und
guckst selber im Internet auf Militär flüge.de
egal ob Irak Mali oder Mallorca die Jungs von
militärflüge.de finden für dich den billigsten
und schönsten Flug an die Front und noch ein Typ
für Sparfüchse wenn du ein riesengebietest
Buch erstmal nur den Hinflug euer Kaliban
[Musik]
Problem gelöst oder nicht klar und jetzt will von
alleine dieses hyperaktive Frettchen ja auch noch
eine eigene kampfdrohne entwickeln zusammen mit
Franzosen und Italienern ja das klingt wie so
ein alter Witz ein Deutscher ein Italiener
und ein Franzose bauen zusammen eine Drohne
sagt der Franzose ich finanziere das Ding sagt
der Italiener ich der liefere Punkte nicht alle
Teile sagt der deutsche und ich gewinne damit mal
einen Krieg wow haha ur Alter drohnenwitz Ural